let me let me pull this story because i
think
regular people are waking up
the narrative is breaking
from timcast.com pennsylvania
republicans increase voter registration
shrinking gap in predominantly democrat
state for every republican voter who has
registered as a democrat
four former democrats have become
republicans
four times as many switching the other
direction
i wanna i always give a shout out to
scott pressler are you familiar with
scott pressler not really the
persistence on twitter this guy's been
going out registering
all over the place he was cleaning up
cities now this is a guy who gets you
know gets he does the work and partly uh
due to his work and truth be told
there's many other activists who are
working towards voter registration as
well we're now starting to see the tides
shift i don't think the republican party
will be the salvation of anybody unless
people vote in the primaries and they do
kind of what we're seeing up in new
hampshire with the free state project
you see that
getting a bunch of you know populist
america first libertarian-minded people
to run
and then we're going to see some
positive changes but this is massive and
again it's indicative of people saying
we've had enough the economy is in the
gutter we don't like joe biden it's been
a year and already we're seeing this
massive shift and it's also people
snapping out of the media narrative i
want to show you one thing before we all
start diving into this take a look at
this from the generic congressional vote
2022 republicans have a lead of 3.6
points
so we're still a bit uh a bit out take a
look at 2020 the democrats had the lead
in the generic congressional polling
aggregate the entire time ending with a
6.8 lead and republicans still made
powerful gains especially in democrat
strongholds what are we going to see in
november it's going to be
this november is going to be a wipeout i
think unless the only thing that could
stop it and it's not going to happen is
joe biden basically saying uh well you
know i think the environment matters but
the new green deal is finished you know
if he actually turns against the left
because remember like obama biden ran as
a centrist that was the whole point of
joe biden and you know one thing people
forget about obama he was a very popular
guy obviously a very charismatic and
kind of likable guy and and people liked
him
every democrat except him was voted out
of office during his term
there was like two there was like two
democrats still working the rest of them
were you know a malt shop somewhere so
so that people do not like these
programs but you saw you saw the state
of the union with biden right yeah it
was it was sort of the
we're still hoping to do things of the
union yes because
what's the state of the union campaign
speech but i mean
he talks about border security he says
i'm a capitalist he was he was just we
should actually refund fund the police
that's right yes he did he said we need
to secure the border he's he's he's he's
trying to get the characters
in the field of dreams and i mean how
stupid does he think well i guess i
guess
itself people switching parties is proof
that people are not stupid they're
waking up and they realize joe biden is
spitting in their faces
i i agree and i i don't even i don't
even know is joe biden running the
country i have no idea but whoever is i
mean really
the aoc bernie sanders wing of the party
is completely in control they believe as
aoc just said on the air she said we've
got gotta be more uh left-wing because
you know
let them that's the way i feel too yeah
go for it i think it's the bankers that
are controlling the country i saw an
andrew jackson quote from 1830 where he
called the bankers the nes of den of
vipers
and then he was attempted they tried to
kill him they shot somebody shot him two
and he broke up the central bank i agree
to a certain degree right obviously the
federal reserve you know we all have our
problems with but uh i think what
happened to the democrats is they saw
aoc in the rise of the progressives and
they thought we can wield this power but
little did they realize it was like the
one ring and they would not be able yeah
that's right well biden has always
followed the uh drift of his party
during clinton uh he was kind of
conservative i mean he wrote the uh
anti-crime bill that everybody's
complaining about you know so he always
has followed the drift of his party he
is you know
they call it leading from behind i mean
it's leading from your ass basically but
i mean but i mean he has always followed
what where the power in his party is and
right now the energy the power in his
party is from on the left but not the
majority i mean she follows the party so
closely like he literally steals their
backstories when he talks about it why
am i the first biden to not work in a
coal mine the first bite yeah well you
got you got you you do got to give joe
biden credit for for one thing he he's
brought a few things to the white house
that we've not seen any president bring
before and it's batacaf care next
norescent and trinidad
i really appreciate the true known
chabot of the pressure that he placed uh
game changing game
i have to say you guys do that really
well i can't imitate that it's like it's
like another one it's probably to your
credit that you can't
next no resent
batacaf care those are easy but trinidad
trunin in the shop under pressure
to pressure by the way we uh trinity
shop under pressure we turned it into a
song and made it a cartoon called
biden's greatest hits you guys better go
check that out someone said it's true
indoor dash shabbat to depressure yes
and no i i do see how you might hear
that but i i listened to that over and
over again and reap repeat trying to
transcribe what he said to figure it out
trinidad of pressure yeah the double in
and uh yeah the trinity
true international
something under pressure i think that's
what he was attempting international
cooperation
like the whisperer yeah well we've been
we talked about it before yeah he does
that little whisper it's very
concerning
about him going with the flow is like
that this uh this weird kind of i don't
know how to describe it this movement of
like
left
this communist ideologies that are kind
of creepy and it seems like he's giving
it to them like he's just letting it
happen because he feels like that's
where the pressure's coming from is
these we gotta do what the young people
want man i don't know
what he's why but it seems like he's
just folding somebody told him or he
told himself that with a 50 50 split in
congress in the senate certainly but
really across the board he was going to
become fdr and that's just not the way
politics works it's not the way american
politics work he does not have the votes
to do the things that he wanted to do
and people didn't want them done joe
manchin you know it's funny joe manchin
actually represents
a more popular point of view than aoc
does i mean if you just count counted
people who agreed checked off what he
manchin believes in they would follow
him but aoc is more popular because
she's pretty she's popular to the press
and she's popular you remember she's
well i'm not saying you're beautiful if
that's what you're asking i was gonna i
was are the beautiful i was gonna do a
similar joke but i was gonna say uh ian
would you give up all your followers
then i was gonna say it too but i was
like you know what it would be a bad
look to compliment ian you're all gonna
die eventually
you see you see the story that aoc uh
the fbc says that they failed to report
a million dollars in expenses that it
seems that they were funneling money
dark money between two different
organizations run by psychic chakra
barty this sounds like a racist sexist
thing to say yeah
this is to me the fascinating thing and
i don't hear anybody talking about this
all these socialists are supported by
the rich and i i don't i wonder does aoc
ever wake up in like in the middle of
the night and think why are the biggest
corporations on earth agreeing with me
i'm a socialist i mean to take their
property away why are they agreeing with
me or does she know that socialism
always serves the rich and the power she
seemed to change about a year and a half
ago something snapped in her brain and
now she's like i i it's weird she's like
on board with that thing it feels like
it it's never changed in a rhetoric
power did you guys ever see the episode
of simpsons where
someone asks homer to listen and he says
you have my undivided attention and then
it zooms into his brain and it's uh it's
playing monkey with the symbols right no
no no it's an old cartoon with that
i kind of imagine that when i see her
like doing interviews or talking because
she's she said things
and that are so absurd you'd think she
doesn't have access to a dictionary or
google yeah like when she talked about
capitalism she was like
no one's a capitalist because they're
not rich it's like
those things don't don't connect what do
you talk what are you talking about you
know what google that did you do that
before you said it another one of her
greatest hits is when she was
complaining about the fact that people
say that universal healthcare is going
to cost a lot of money and she said well
why don't people talk about all the
money we're going to save when we don't
have to pay for as many funerals
it's like do you think people stop dying
if we have no they eat more sugar
oh she said she saved money uh yeah it
was her district because amazon didn't
move there they're like why are they
giving money to amazon they're not
they're giving them a discount on the
taxes they would pay like so the 30
billion dollars the city would get and
the jobs
right right right so it's like amazon
would instead would pay 27 billion
instead of 30 billion because they're
getting a three billion discount and
she's like but why are we giving them
three billion dollars but here's the
thing so they don't so they don't go to
nationals
is for as many problems as there are
with aoc's thinking socialism being one
of them that's not a unique flaw with
their thinking that's just part of the
socialist ethos this business is only
here exploiting and taking advantage of
our workers the only way we benefit from
them being there is by taking their
money involuntarily so from from their
perspective they really did lose money
on that is absurd as that sounds
but they were either way going to take
money from amazon just a little bit less
but they don't see it that way because
amazon was going to come there and
exploit their workers yeah socialists
never ask themselves where the money
comes from yeah i love i love going on
these posts i'll see on facebook where
it's like
uh uh they say landlord isn't a real job
or they say wage labor is theft and so i
asked a few of these socialists some
questions i was like what if the people
who rent my property are paying less
than the cost of maintaining and
upkeeping the property is that theft and
they're like that makes no sense
what do you mean like sometimes people
rent out a property and it will cost
more than the amount they're paying in
rent so who's being robbed now yeah
that's like no no good answer i said
what if i'm paying the employee more
money than they generate for the company
is that theft and they're like that's
not possible
i'm like yeah it's called investment
mm-hmm like
you couldn't exhaust a project that's
making no money but you're hoping to
make money in the long term so you're
giving your money to somebody who's
making no money for you in the hopes
they eventually will and then you'll get
paid back right they're like well then
you're an idiot
that's literally what i was told on
facebook well that's like that's like
when they women demand equal pay for the
same sport and you go like nobody's
watching the sport nobody's watching
women's sports you know it's just like
they will now that men are playing them
but but still you know
and you know you get paid the money that
you bring in i was uh i actually knew
the people who got uh
the at the x games they used to pay
women 10 of what the men got paid and so
this is the story as it was told to me
because i actually ended up going to the
x games as like a an advisor liaison or
whatever with one of these organizations
so a good friend of mine was one of the
top female skateboarding pros uh for a
while
and what i was told by these people
at the x games they would give i think
it was like thirty thousand dollars to
the first place male winner and the
first place female winner would get
three thousand dollars and when this
group of you know uh parents and
organizers went to disney to espn or
whatever whoever runs it said you're
paying women 10 like that's
not fair and they said
look at the stands
how many people are there watching you
guys you don't sell any tickets we can't
pay you money we don't have well after
some clever negotiating and some good pr
tactics eventually they agreed
we're going to pay the same what the
argument was from the organizers is
we have the best female skateboarders in
the world if you can't sell tickets you
have a marketing problem
and so they said you're going to pay
the same you're going to pay and so
eventually they agreed there's a really
interesting backstory behind it i don't
know if it's public so i'll refrain but
that was their mentality i think there's
a decent point there to be honest
well if there is
if if you're going to invest
in in in a show
and you're saying the going rate for the
top athletes in a division is x
you're investing hoping that you can
figure how to monetize it if you if you
want top athletes
and you're you and and you can't figure
out how to sell those top athletes then
then i'd argue get rid of the division
outright instead of just being like well
that certainly would have been one
answer but i don't understand i mean it
may be there's just less demand yeah
exactly i mean if it's a problem with
marketing why don't these female
skateboarders get together rent a
stadium hire a competent marketer and
make just as much money as the men well
that would require tens of millions of
investment they didn't have
potentially but they could start smaller
and they'd still be generating more
income than this business that is just
failing to market them when you come to
performance-based jobs you got to pay
people based on their performance and if
the girls can't jump as high sorry it's
not you're not performing as well but
look at women's tennis women's tennis
makes a ton of money but that's
because women's tennis is almost a
different game i love tennis and women's
tennis is a almost a different game and
in some ways a better game because it's
slower and you can see it
oh that's so it brings and and they wear
those cute little dresses so that means
like you know it brings people in you
know no but that's but that's that's
that's
right
everything everything you i i never
liked the williams sisters not because
any personal atmos but they were so
strong that they kind of overwhelmed
people because i always liked the slower
women's game because it's just more
strategic and more interesting the the
vol the rallies last longer uh it's it's
just more fun so it makes money women's
volleyball too i've always had this is
interesting i don't know so uh the guy
who actually led the charge for wins
tennis in the 80s is the same guy who
was leaving the same charge for women's
skateboarding so i i think i think
there's a there's there's still an
agreement there i think
perhaps they need to create a different
structure and stop trying to just
replicate men's with women and maybe
make something different well i i'm all
for that i think that that is one of the
big mistakes of feminism is they're
always trying to make the women men even
in in how they live their lives like
women start their careers early
because of the feminists say their
careers are important i think why not
have the babies early and then have your
career afterwards it makes a lot more
sense just because men do it one way
doesn't mean women have to do it the
same way i'll tell you man uh
there's this woman i know
she had a kid when she was in her
mid-20s
so
this is what which she told me
her and this guy were both doing the
same kind of work
they were working in um like media
production
she ends up having a kid and took off
only a little bit of time to
you know take maternity time off and
then raise the kid but it it
disproportionately held her back because
there's an exponential gain to working
non-stop when you're young
and so you know she was pointing out
that she's now in her 30s and she's half
the distance of the guy who never took
any time off sure but that that that
said i said to that i'm like i don't
know if there's any solution to that
because women literally have babies and
men don't yes and and also maybe she got
something else that men didn't have and
maybe she had a life that she liked
better you know she got to have a kid
yeah and spent time with her kid and
that other guy did it's a nice thing
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you